you know ilhan omar is one of the
members of the squad she is a far left
progressive she's basically a socialist
a marxist a communist it doesn't matter
what word you're using to describe her
she deeply hates the united states
i am not editorializing there she's
telling you she came here from sudan she
is as
as a first generation immigrant she has
amassed enormous power she has come here
in essence to destroy this country she
she hates the police she hates our
founding she believes the place is
systemically racist she wants it overrun
with immigrants these are all her
policies right i'm just repeating her
policies with a little bit of extra
juice today um but no i said juice there
not jews she don't like the jews either
but that's something else um
uh well now one of the things that she
has done in minneapolis which she has
wrecked she has absolutely wrecked
minneapolis it is one of the places
where people are leaving nobody's going
honey let's move to minneapolis no
they're getting the hell out of
minneapolis right now well one of the
things that she did in the last year and
a half in the midst of all of this uh
black lives matter and antifa
destruction of cities that you know you
don't really uh talk about because in
polite company you know those are the
good guys when they're destroying cities
um she was all about defunding the
police right and of course you all know
when you defund the police that then is
the hint to the criminals to do more bad
stuff so in places like portland and
seattle and new york and san francisco
and minneapolis crime is through the
roof in all of these places literally
every metric that they check
murder armed robberies
uh you know the whole thing like every
prostitution everything that could go
wrong is going wrong in all these cities
it's thanks to people like ilhan omar
but you're not going to believe this
she's not looking at herself
ilhan omar does not have a mirror where
she might go you know i really screwed
this one she's blaming the police
themselves take a listen what
we must also recognize
is that the reduction in policing
currently in our city
and the lawlessness that is happening
um is
due to two things
one the police have chosen
to not
fulfill
their oath of office
and to provide
the public safety they are owed
to the citizens they serve
right it's documented
but even before that it was documented
the minneapolis police department is the
most dysfunctional
police department in our state and
probably in the country
man
she is no good
when i talk about these people that
blatantly lie to you that stare at you
in the eyes and lie to you
what can we deduce other than they have
really bad intentions like i don't think
she's an idiot i don't like her but i
will give the devil his due i think she
knows exactly what she is doing so i can
only then deduce from that that this is
a very bad person she is the one that
has demonized the police over the past
two years she is the one who has
defunded the police and she dare
say that the police have chosen not to
uphold their duty
how dare you you're the one that has
demonized them you are the one that has
caused many of them to retire and not
want to work
in these departments in your city
because of your rhetoric she hates
america she hates america there's just
no other way uh to say it she wants to
destroy this place and to give the devil
as due once again she's doing it that's
what we have let these progressives do
and we gotta push back but we are
pushing back we're pushing back not only
as i said earlier on the technological
side but more and more parents are
showing up to school board meetings
which by the way there's a extraordinary
video of merrick garland uh getting
crushed today because you know he had
basically claimed that parrots were were
domestic terrorists who show up to uh to
school board meetings to fight against
critical race theory and the whole thing
was based on a bunk note that has now
been retracted which i had predicted
about five days ago i was on jesse
kelly's show i literally made a joke
about the piece of paper that it was
written on
anyway
some of the cities are just going to go
down and other people are just going to
build great things